[Musique]
Désolé, je ne vous dérangerais pas ici,
mais vos gens n'arrêtent pas de me dire que vous n'êtes
pas disponible,
vous savez que vous pourriez vraiment faire plus
pour cette ville
[Musique]
Ma famille a une histoire de philanthropie,
mais pour autant que je sache  tu ne
fais rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'
énigme te demande
le tueur a laissé ça pour le batman pourquoi
court-il vers toi
est-ce que tu vas bien
j'ai essayé de te joindre
bon il y a le dernier c'est tout à propos des
ailes
si nous ne nous levons pas, personne n'auras-
tu beaucoup de chats tout sur la
force
la chauve-souris et le chat
il a une belle bague nouveau ami à toi
je ne suis pas si sûr que
je suis juste ici pour démasquer la vérité à
ce sujet  oui
tu fais partie de ça aussi
comment est-ce que je fais partie de ça
oh tu n'es vraiment pas aussi intelligent que je le
pensais
grandit
toutes ces années
tu m'as menti alfred
nous avons tous nos cicatrices bruce tu es toujours
absent
il est impliqué  dans ce oh il n'est pas
impliqué comment savez-vous
[Musique]
qui êtes-vous là-dessous
que cachez-vous  g
ne t'inquiète pas chérie j'en ai neuf
ça peut être poétique cruel ou aveugle
mais quand c'est nié
c'est ta violence tu peux trouver
justice
la justice de la réponse
]
vous